تقول جريده ذا جارديان ان عشرات العمال من
نيبال توفوا في قطر خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
وهم ينشئون بنيه كاس العالم لكره القدم
التي ستنظمها البلاد عام
2022 ووفقا للصحيفه وطبقا لبعض الوثائق
التي حصلت عليها من سفاره نيبال في الدوحه
فقد مات 44 عاملا في الفتره الممتده بين
الرابع من يونيو والثامن من اغسطس ويوجد
ما يقارب من ال90 الف عامل حاليا في قطر
وتدعي الصحيفه ان الكثير من اصحاب العمل
الشباب لا يدفعون اجور العاملين ويقومون
بمصادره جوازات سفرهم وهناك
ادعاءات بحرمان العمال من الحصول على مياه
الشرب في الحر
الشديد ويقول الصحفي الذي قام بالتحقيق في
لقاء مع سي ان ان بيت بيترسون انه نجح في
الوصول الى بعض العمال وابلغه بعضهم انهم
لم يح صل على رواتبهم منذ اشهر بهدف منعهم
من الهروب وترك العمل كما تحدث البعض عن
مصادره جوازات سفرهم وعدم منحهم بطاقات
هويه مما يجعلهم حكما يعملون بنظام
السخره يضيف بيت انه في كثير من المرات لم
يتم اعطاء هؤلاء العمال مياها للشرب في
مواقع عملهم مما يضطرهم لمغادره الموقع
الى مسجد قريب للحصول عليها وقال ان هناك
بعض العمال الذين فق وظائفهم لم يستطيعوا
الرجوع لبلادهم فلجوا لسفاره
نيبال وردت لجنه قطر
2002 المسؤوله عن استضافه بطوله كاس
العالم في بيان حصلت سي ان ان على نسخه
منه انه سيتم التحقيق في هذه الادعاءات
منوه الى انها تؤمن بشده بحق المعامله
الانسانيه للعاملين المنخرطين
بمشاريعها